Five four,
three.
Dos Uno,
come on.
Tri caster.
Live well live ladies and gentlemen to my left,
uh,
Tim Timple,
everybody knows and loves him.
Viga,
what does it,
how do you,
how do I pronounce your last name?
Good job.
Not Vieja.
Vigia Vigia Gadi Gadi and your position at Twitter is I lead trust and safety.
Legal and public policy.
That's a lot.
And Jack Dorsey,
ladies and gentlemen.
Um,
first of all,
thank you everybody for doing this.
Appreciate it.
Thank you.
It feels the feels all of a sudden there's tension in the room.
We're all loosey Goosey.
Just a few minutes of your attention.
Never one's like,
oh,
this is really happening.
Here we go.
Um,
before we get started we should say,
because there were some things that people wanted to,
uh,
have us talk about.
One that the cash APP is one of the sponsors of the podcast.
It's been a sponsor for a long time and also a giant supporter of my good friend
Justin is fight for the forgotten charity,
building wells for the pygmies in the Congo.
This is very important to me and I'm very happy that you guys are a part of that
and you are connected to that.
I don't,
uh,
that's,
I mean it's easy for someone to say that doesn't have an influence on the way we
discuss things,
but it doesn't,
so if it does,
I don't know what to tell you.
I'm going to mention too,
just because I don't want people to come out and freak out later.
I actually have like 80 shares in square,
which isn't really that much in,
but,
but it's something,
it is,
it is.
So I don't want people to think,
you know,
whatever you,
you're the CEO of square I think,
right?
Yup.
Yeah.
There you go.
Well,
there you go.
We have the cash APP.
And the reason why we decided to come together is,
um,
we had,
I thought,
a great conversation last time,
but there's a lot of people that were upset that there were some issues that we
didn't discuss or didn't discuss in depth enough or they felt that I didn't
press you enough.
I talked to Tim because Tim and I have talked before and he made a video about
it and I felt like his criticism was very valid.
So we got on the phone and we talked about it and I knew immediately within the
first few minutes of the conversation that he was far more educated about this
than I was.
So I said,
would you be willing to do a podcast and perhaps do a podcast with Jack?
And he said,
absolutely.
So we did a podcast together.
It was really well received.
People felt like we covered a lot of the issues that they felt like I didn't
bring up.
And so then Jack and I had discussed it and we said,
well,
let's bring Tim on and then have Vigia on as well.
I say that right?
Yeah,
that's a hard one.
Sorry.
I'll get it right.
I promise.
Uh,
but so we're here,
we're here,
um,
today.
Uh,
you know,
do you know who Sean Baker is?
He's a doctor who's a prominent proponent of the carnivore diet.
His post was,
his account was frozen today.
I just sent it to Jamie.
Yeah,
his count was frozen today because of an image that he had,
because he's a proponent of the carnivore diet.
There's a lot people that believe that this elimination diet is very healthy for
you and it's known to cure a lot of autoimmune issues with certain people,
but some people ideologically opposed it because they think it's bad for the
environment or you shouldn't eat meat or whatever the reasons are.
This is huge.
And the bitcoin community,
yes,
yes.
Yeah.
Well,
it's the,
for a lot of people that have autoimmune issues with particularly psoriasis and
arthritis is,
is a lifesaver.
It's crazy.
It's essentially,
it's an autoimmune issue,
so because he has a photo of a lion in a header eating a looks like a wheel to
beats or something like that,
his account was locked for violating these rules,
rules against graphic violence or adult content in profile images.
That seems a little silly and I wanted to just mention that right away.
Now,
whose decision is something like that,
like who decides to lock a guy's account out because it has a nature image?
If you know natural predatory behavior
on this particular case,
it's probably an algorithm that detected it and made some sort of an assessment.
But as a general rule,
how we operate as a company as we rely on people to report information to us.
So if you look at any tweet and you can kind of pull down on the carrot on the
right and you can say report the tweet and then you have a bunch of categories
you can choose from what you want to report.
Um,
I think this one in particular though,
it was probably an algorithm.
So how does,
does it,
does he have the option to protest that or to ask someone to review it?
Absolutely.
And I,
I,
I'm guessing that people are already reviewing it,
but there's a choice to appeal any action and that would go to a human to make
sure that it is actually a violation of the rules.
Or in this case,
if it's not,
then it would be removed.
Is that a violation of the rules,
that image?
I don't think so.
I don't think that that would be what we're trying to capture in terms of
graphic images and an avatar.
It's more about violence towards,
uh,
humans,
unless it was some sort of cruelty depicting the walls or something like that.
But this seems not the intention of the rule
does this high.
This one of the reasons why I wanted to bring this up immediately.
Does this highlight a flaw in the system in that people can target an individual
cause with him,
he's uh,
he,
like I said,
he's a doctor and a proponent of this carnivore die,
but he's also,
he ruthless in his condemnation and mocking of vegans.
He does it all the time and so then they get upset at him and they can target
posts and just report them and mass.
And when they do that,
then this becomes an issue.
I think this does reveal part of,
um,
you know,
the challenges that we face as a global platform at scale.
In this part,
I don't,
I don't know what happened in this case,
sorry.
It's hard for me to talk about it.
But what I would say is that it doesn't really matter if one person reports it
or 10,000 people report it.
Like we're going to review the reports and we're going to make an assessment and
we're never going to,
you know,
kick someone off the platform finally and forever without a person taking a look
and making sure that it's an actual violation of,
right.
Right.
Okay.
So put the mob reporting
behavior does happen.
Yeah,
it does.
It happens across the spectrum.
I'd have to assume it's going to be one direction.
I,
I can't imagine he would target vegans,
but vegans would talk at him.
Right.
Well,
he might,
I mean he does.
Is he the kind of guy is going to want to report to vegans and get them banned
from Twitter or is he gonna want to make fun of them?
He's going to make fun of them.
They're going to target him trying to get them removed by exploiting the system
that you guys have.
It may not be him though.
It could also be his followers.
It's a really complicated world out there.
So you don't,
the motivations of why people mop report are different and it's not always some
under someone's control.
It could ease and even be other carnivores,
dire proponents who are just jerks that don't like him because he's getting all
the love people were weird.
Yeah,
but it's history.
The idea though is that it does kind of highlight a bit of a flaw in that it's
good that someone could like,
cause you might see something awful,
someone doxing someone or something like that and then you can take that and
report it and then people can see it and get rid of it and minimize the damage
that's done.
That there's another big problem here and that is the Carnivore Diet
legitimately healthy?
Is it a threat to your health?
And if it is is what is Twitter's responsibility in controlling that
information?
Right.
So just to clarify,
my,
my opinion is if he wants to be a proponent for the carnivore diet,
let them,
but you've got people on Youtube who are being direct for certain beliefs about
certain health issues that I don't agree with.
And so one of the risks then is,
you know,
we're coming towards a position where people think some ideas are better than
others.
Therefore,
as a company we're going to restrict access to certain information.
You mean like anti-vaccine?
Exactly.
So,
so I guess I'm trying to say is at what would you guys restrict someone from
sharing info like false information about vaccines that could get someone hurt
that is not a violation of Twitter roles?
No,
I think,
I mean that'd be interesting to hear your ideas around this book or our
perspective right now is,
um,
around this concept of variety of perspective.
Like are we,
are we encouraging more echo chambers and filter bubbles or we at least showing
people other information that might be counter to what they see.
And there's,
there's a bunch of research that would suggest that further emboldens or views.
There's also research that suggests that it at least gives them a consideration
about what their,
what they currently believe.
So would you guys,
oh,
go ahead.
Sorry.
Given the dynamics of our network being completely public,
we're not organized around communities.
We're not organized around topics.
Um,
we have a little bit more freedom to show more of the spectrum of any one
particular issue.
And I think that's how we would,
we would approach it from the start.
That said,
we haven't really dealt much with misinformation more broadly across like these
sorts of topics.
We've,
we've focused our efforts on elections and um,
well mainly election trainer.
Yeah.
You thought it was a different animal.
You know,
someone can really convince you that the earth is flat.
If you're gullible and you watch a 45 minute youtube video right now it's kind
of a different thing.
But I want to,
I wanted to just kind of get into that statement you made about misinformation
and whether or not you'll police it.
So I think that the tough part of this is really an love to have a discussion
about this is do you really want corporations to police what's true and not
true?
Absolutely not.
So really,
really tough position.
But you guys do that.
We try not to do that.
We don't want to do that.
But please when your rules,
but the places that we focus on is where we think that people are going to be
harmed by this in a direct and tangible way that we feel a responsibility to
correct,
correct ourselves rules.
Tim,
what do you mean by that?
Gender dead naming and Miss Gender.
That's a specific ideology that's unique to a very small faction of people in
this world that you guys actually banned people for.
So the way I think of it is it's behavior based.
And I know you think of that as content and we can,
we can disagree on this point,
but this is about why are you doing this to a trans person?
Why are you calling them by this name when they've chosen to go by a different
name or why are you outing them in some way?
Like what is your intent and purpose behind that?
But in the interest of clarity,
I wanted to explain what deadnaming means.
Right?
Right.
So,
so,
uh,
a transgender individual changes their name when they transition.
A dead name would be the birth name or the name they went by before the
transition though.
So it was my mom's probably going,
what the text once a debt name.
And I will clarify to your role specifically they targeted mis-gendering and
deadnaming I believe it's correct.
Right?
So years ago we,
we passed a policy that we call our hateful conduct policy and that prohibits
targeting or attacking someone based on their belonging in any number of groups,
whether it's because of their religion or their race or their gender,
their sexual orientation and their gender identity.
So it was something that's broad based is that you can't choose to attack people
because of these characteristics,
but you do have limits on what characteristics you police.
Right?
So you're not,
you're not a banning people,
but for targeted transpi seeing others.
Right.
I will,
we have also general abuse and harassment roles,
right?
Which says you can't engage in abuse and harassment on the platform,
but you can't designate someone,
but you can call them stupid.
Uh,
generally,
I mean,
if you created an account that,
uh,
only was there to call the same person stupid 5,000 times,
we'd probably view that as the,
you know,
targeted,
harassed,
targeted harassment.
It's a function of the bit,
it's a function of behavior because people with our system can do this massive
velocity ultimately silence you from a platform or to say like I give up,
I don't want to deal with this thing.
Also there's a,
so we can just get into all of the big examples.
I mean,
uh,
starting with the to Tim,
but can we just take a step back and try to level set of what we're trying to do
with our policies because I think it's worth doing.
Yes.
So as,
as a,
as a high level,
I personally,
and this is my job to run the policy team,
I believe that everyone has a voice and should be able to use it and I want them
to be able to use it online.
Now,
where we draw a line is when people use their voice and use their platform to
abusing her ass,
other people to silence them.
Because I think that that's what we've seen over the years is a number of people
who have been silenced online because of the abuse and harassment they've
received.
And they either stop talking or they leave the platform and its entirety.
If you look at free expression and free speech laws around the world,
they're not absolute.
They're not.
Absolutely.
There's always limitations on what you can say and it's when you're starting to
endanger other people.